welcome back to cbs mornings since the
pandemic began certain types of violent
crime have been on the rise in this
country we're learning more about the
impact of that violence on victims
families including those in law
enforcement in 2020 we saw the highest
numbers of gun murders in america since
1968 a 34 percent increase from the year
before
jeff begaye spoke with two men working
to help victims of violent crime they're
both profoundly shaped by their own
family's experience with it
losing a loved one to murder is the
worst thing that could ever happen to
anybody sergeant ben brown solves
homicides in prince george's county
maryland never thought it would touch me
in my personal life in 2020 the
senseless violence he usually fights in
the streets
hit home for him and his wife donna
their 17-year-old son bradley was gunned
down steps from their house police say
bradley was selling thc vape cartridges
when his killers tried to rob him and he
died in the family's driveway i go out
there almost every day and i have the
thoughts of him laying there with rising
crime and homicides in cities and towns
across america
more victims and families are faced with
grief that the legal system is often
unable to heal 50 percent of all
homicides across the country went
unsolved in 2020 and even for the cases
that are cracked the road to justice can
still be painfully long one of the men
involved in bradley's death has been
sentenced to life in prison but another
suspect goes on trial later this year
more than two years after the crime do
you think at times victims are forgotten
in this talk about rise and crime across
the country unfortunately all too
frequently assistant attorney general
kenneth pallid leads the justice
department's criminal division this year
his office has brought in its first
victim rights coordinator the reality is
that
the criminal justice system
often doesn't provide enough
i can't bring back a loved one to a
family no matter what sentence the
criminal justice system imposes belite
grew up in new orleans lower ninth ward
he is a prosecutor who sees violent
crime through the eyes of law
enforcement
and victims i lost my
half brother to the streets of new
orleans very violently as well growing
up his family kept him on track he
credits a mother who was dedicated to a
success
and a father who was a 37-year veteran
of the new orleans police department
but polite says his half-brother's
murder
is why he's working at the justice
department i think his death in a lot of
ways shaped me and
led me to want to become a prosecutor
believe says victims are at the center
of the work that his office is doing the
criminal division is updating its victim
policies and procedures
including possible legislative changes
to victims rights statutes do you have
the resources that you need we could
absolutely use more to ensure that we
are bringing
those victims into our work as early as
possible making sure that our decision
making is being informed by their
interest he says mistrust of police by
minority communities
is one of the hurdles he's trying to
tackle i've seen the worst of law
enforcement i've seen what it meant what
it means for victims not to come forward
i've seen what it means for witnesses
not willing to come into a courtroom to
support our cases which can often lead
to delayed prosecutions as was the case
for polite's family it took about 10
years for your family to get justice
some sliver of justice i would say
sergeant ben brown says the most
important thing for all victims
is to not give up the hope for justice
there are things you can do to promote
the case and try and get justice you're
telling people to keep the pressure on
people like you
who investigate these cases absolutely
you have to
you don't want them to ever forget
unfortunately violence is a part of the
american experience and we need to do
better in order to prevent these
families from going through that type of
pain